the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright so anyway I'm the engine
director and some games taking that
position previously I was working on and
I've worked at Sony I've worked at it
I've worked for Titus and blue sky
studios in San Diego so when I've been a
game development 12 years before that I
was working in simulation so the
PlayStation 3 is a really fun platformer
and I know you guys have been working on
cell development working with the ps3
under Linux working as developers for
the ps3 is definitely a different
environment than that I think I'm going
to concentrate more on the high level
aspects of how you design a game for the
cell and how the cell would impact a
design and what are the elements of the
game just stuff that you probably
haven't had as part of this course that
you might find interesting and you can
feel free to interrupt me at any time
questions or whatever you'd like
so just I wanted to go over briefly to
some of the different types of game
development and what the trade-offs for
each one of them are casual games
console games PC games although casual
games basically are the small simple
games that you would download on the PC
or or you'd see on Yahoo or whatever and
those generally don't have really strict
performance requirements where a console
game we have the particular advantage of
knowing the hardware and the hardware
isn't change for entire cycle so first
five six years we have exactly the same
hardware and that's definitely an
advantage from a performance point of
view and in this case its PlayStation 3
4 as far as development priorities
development priorities for a console
game and especially ps3 game development
would be completely different than you
might find on another kind of
application we don't really consider the
code itself important at all the real
value is in the programmers the real
values in the experience is in those
skills code is disposable
we after six years when we start a new
platform we pretty much have to read it
anyway so there's no there's not much
point in trying to plan for a long life
span of code especially when you have
optimized code written in assembly for a
particular platform and to that end the
data is what is way more significant
performance than the code anyway and the
data is specific to a particular game or
specific or specific to a particular
type of game and certainly a specific to
a Studios pipeline and it's the design
of the data where you really want to
spend your time concentrating especially
for the ps3 ease of programming whether
or not it's easier to do parallelism is
not a major concern at all if it's if
it's hard so what you do it that's it
portability runs on the PlayStation 3
doesn't run anywhere else that's a non
concern and everything is about
performance everything we do a vast
majority of our code is either hand up
to my C or assembly
very little high-level code some of our
gameplay programmers will write C++ for
the high level logic but as as Jenna
mostly code that's running most of the
time is definitely no that's not
necessarily true if we have games that
share similar share similar needs I can
definitely share some more code I mean
the the point I'm trying to make is
let's say in order to make something
fast it has to be complicated so be it
it's complicated
whether or not it's easy to use for
another programmer is not a major
concern no I don't care the most high
the highest performance tool it exists
is the brains of the programmers our
team you cannot create it's it's
theoretically impossible you cannot out
perform people who are customizing for
the data for the for the context for the
game it is not even remotely
theoretically possible
and there's the day would have lots of
true for your general Ripper everybody
that's it absolutely I could eat know
the average person the average person
we're not the average female birthday
programmers yeah absolutely cost doesn't
become an issue or you figure out a new
way of doing it or do a little bit less
I mean you do have to prioritize what
you want to do I feel the day you can do
everything you want to do and you have
another game you need to [ __ ] eventually
anyway so a lot of times you do end up
tabeling things and say look we can get
50% more performance out of this but
we're gonna have to table that for now
and scale back on the content and that's
why you have six years of development
you know maybe in the next cycle in the
next game you'll be able to squeeze a
little bit more and the next one you
squeeze out a little bit more that's
sort of this continuous development and
continuous optimization over the course
of a platform and sometimes yeah I mean
occasionally you just say it's yeah we
can't do it or whatever it doesn't work
I mean some ideas just don't pan out but
there's plenty of studios where the
programming complexity has killed the
studio or killed the project but I find
it hard to believe or it's very rarely
because its complexity that has to do
specifically with optimization
it's that complexity usually has to do
with unnecessary complexity come let's
see that doesn't achieve anything
organization for the sake of
organization so you have this sort of
over design C++ hierarchies just for the
sake of over organizing things that's
what will generally kill a project but
in performance the complexity tends to
come from the rule set what you need to
set it up but the code tends to be
smaller when it's fast
you're tend to be doing one thing and
doing one thing really well so it
doesn't tend to get out of hand
I mean it occasionally happens but yeah
how big is this programming versus the
other aspect okay drama team so so how
many programmers how many artists so
artists are by far the most the largest
group of developers so you have
animators and shader artists and Picture
Arts and modelers environmental artists
and lighters and so they can they
they'll often outnumber programmers two
to one which is completely different
than certainly very different from
Playstation and the gap is much larger
than it wasn't a petition to with
programmers you tend to have a fairly
even split or you tend to have a divide
between the high level gameplay
programmers and the low level engine
programmers so and you will tend to have
more game play programmers than engine
programmers
although most the majority of the CPU
time is spent in the engine code and
that partially comes down to education
and experience in order to get high
performance code you need to have that
experience you need to know how to
optimize you need to understand the
Machine you need to understand the
architecture and you need to understand
the data and there is only so many
people that can do that on any
particular team
just like the amount of code yeah yeah I
mean it's hard to say I mean because it
depends on how many features you're
using you know and sort of the scope of
the engine is how much is being used for
a particular game especially if you're
you're targeting multiple games and it's
within a studio but quite often
interestingly enough the gameplay code
actually overwhelms the engine code in
terms of size and that is back to
basically what I was saying that the
engine code tends to do one thing really
well or series of things really well
these days it's much more likely that
gameplay code is C++ and high-level and
kills performance and doesn't think
about things like cache so and and
that's but that's actually part of the
problem with Playstation 3 development
as part of the challenge of that we've
had with the PlayStation 3 development
is in the past certainly the PlayStation
2 and definitely on any previous console
you this divide between gameplay and the
engine worked very well you could
basically the gameplay programmers could
just call a function and if we did its
fat thing really fast and they came back
and they continued this but you know in
a single programmer a program on one
process that that model works very well
but now when the high-level design can
destroy performance but through the
simplest decision like for example in
collision detection if the a if the
logic assumes that the result was
immediately available there is no
there's virtually no way of making that
fast so the high level design has to
conform to the hardware so that's the
test sort of the challenge analysis
introducing those concepts to the high
level programmers who haven't
traditionally had to deal with it Oh
does that answer the question as far as
the split you say two to one right
approximately two to one artist
programmers in very soon at the studio
and team the team so it's hard to say as
an industry as a whole so on back to
basically to the point of the code isn't
really important the code itself doesn't
have a lot of value there are
fundamental things that affect how you
would design it in the first place the
type of game you the kind of engine that
would run a racing game is completely
different than the kind of engine that
would run a first-person shooter the
needs are different the optimizations
are totally different that data is
totally different so you wouldn't try to
reuse code from one to the other it just
either wouldn't work or would work
really really poorly the framerate have
having a target of 30 frames per second
is a much different problem than having
a target of 60 frames per second and in
this in the mtsc territories those are
pretty much our only two choices 30
frames or 60 which means everything has
to be done in 16 and 2/3 of milliseconds
that's it that's what you have or 32
milliseconds you know of course that the
schedule one cost how much you know do
you have a two-year cycle a one-year
cycle how much can you get done the kind
of hardware so taking for example a an
engine from PlayStation 2 and trying to
move from PlayStation 3 to PlayStation 3
it's sort of a lost cause there is that
the the kind of optimizations that you
would do the kind of parallelization you
would do is so completely different
although there was parallelization in
the PlayStation 2 the choices would have
been completely different
so there's not much the gain the loss
from trying to port it is much much
greater than the cost of just doing it
again
I don't know that there's an average I
mean if you wanted to just like
homogenize the industry right it means
probably 18 months the compiler actually
makes a huge significant difference and
how you design your code
if you if you're working with GCC and
you have programmers who have been
working with GCC for 15 years
and who understand the intricacies and
and issues involved in GCC the kind of
code you would write would be completely
different than a few using Excel C for
example on the cell and for there are
our studios insomniac dozen but there
are other studios who do cross-platform
designs so for example write PlayStation
3 games and Xbox 360 games or and/or PC
titles at the moment probably the
easiest approach for that is to target
the PlayStation 3 and so you have these
sort of SPU friendly chunks of
processing and SPU trunks friendly
chunks of data and move those on to
homogeneous parallel processors it's not
the perfect solution but virtually all
cross-platform titles are not looking
for the perfect solution anyway because
they cannot fully optimize for any
particular platform I wanted to go
through these are a basic list of some
of them the major modules that a game is
made out of I'll go through some of
these and explain how designing on the
sale impacts the system I'm not gonna
bother reading them I assume you all can
read so yeah I'm gonna go over the major
system a few of the major systems and
then we're going to dive a little bit
into a specific system in this case of
animation system and just talk it
through basically and see how how each
of these steps are affected by the
hardware that we're running on
so just to start with when you're
designing a structure any structure
anywhere those are the initial structure
is affected by the kind of hardware that
you're running and in this particular
case on the SPU and there are other
processes where this is equally true but
on this conventional structure where you
say structure class or whatever and you
and you have domain constrained
structures are of surprisingly little
use in in general the data is either
compressed or is in a stream or is in
blocks it's sorted based on type which
means that there's no there's no fixed
size struct that you could define anyway
so as a general rule the structure of
the data is defined within the code as
opposed to in a struct somewhere and
that's really to get the performance
from the data you group things of
similar type together rather than for
example on the SPU having flags that say
this is of type a this is of type B any
flag and supplies a branch which is I'm
sure you all know at this point is
really poor performing on the SPU so
basically pull flags out ree-ree sort
everything and then move things and
streams and all these types are going to
be a varying sizes in which case there's
very little point to defining the
structures in the first place because
you can't change them oh and the fact
that data you're you're accessing data
in quadwords anyway they're always
either loading and storing in quadwords
non scalars so having scalar fields in a
structure is sort of pointless so again
on the SPU generally speaking structures
are of much use when you go to defining
structures and generally you need to
consider things like the cache the the
the TLB how that's going to affect your
reading out of the structural writing to
the structure
to the point of you you cannot just
assume that if you've written some data
definition that you can port it to
another platform it's very easy to be
poorly performing platform in a platform
in this case when we define when we
design structures you have to consider
the fundamental units of the cell the
cache line is a fundamental unit of the
cell you have basically you want to
define things in terms of 128 bytes the
wide what can you fit in there because
that you read one you read them all so
you want to pack as much as possible
into 120 28 bytes and just deal with
that as a fundamental unit 16 bytes of
course you're doing loading stores
through quadword loading store so you
don't want to have little scalar bits in
there that you're shuffling around just
deal with it as a quad word and don't
deal with anything smaller than that so
basically the minimum working sizes in
practice would be 4 by 128 bits wide and
can split that up regularly however you
want so to that point I think here's an
example of a I want to talk about a
vector class vector classes usually the
the first thing some pro programmer will
jump onto when they might want to make
something for games but in in in real
life it's probably the most useless
thing you could ever write it doesn't
actually do anything we have we have the
image we know the instruction set it's
already in quad words we know the loads
and stores we've already designed your
data so it fits properly this doesn't
give us anything and it potentially
makes things worse the the component had
allowing component access to a quad word
especially on the PPU
is ridiculously bad and if you allow in
practice if you allow component access
higher high level programmers will use
component access so if you have a vector
class that says get X get Y whatever
somebody somewhere is going to use it
which means the performance of the whole
thing just drops and it's
impossible to optimize so as a general
rule you pick your fundamental unit in
this case the for about 100 the 128-bit
unit that I was talking about and you
don't define anything smaller than that
everything is packed into a unit about
that size and yes in practice there will
be some wasted space at the beginning or
end of streams of data groups of data
but it doesn't make much difference
you're gonna have that wasted space if
you are you're gonna have much more than
that in wasted space if you're using
dynamic memory for example which when I
get to it
I don't recommend you use either so so
some things to consider when you're
doing this sort of math transformation
anyway is are you gonna do
floats double fixed point I mean doubles
right out there's no point regardless of
the speed on the SPU of a double there's
no value in it for games we have a known
we have known data so if we need to we
can renormalize a group of of geometry
around a point and get it into the range
of a floating point it's a non-issue so
there's no reason to waste the space and
a double at all unless it was actually
faster which it isn't which so you know
is it the sort of the only real
problematic thing with the ESPE floating
point is its format and not supporting
denormalized numbers is becomes
problematic but again you can work
around it by renormalizing your numbers
within the range that you within a known
range so that it won't get to the point
where it needs to denormalize at least
for the work that you're actually doing
yeah
using me like I'm talking about phone
right every programmer racer on back to
class and I'm saying that that's a
useless exercise in futility don't
bother doing it and don't use anybody
else's either if you're writing for the
cell you have the SA you if you're
writing an C you have the SI intrinsics
they're already in quad words you can do
everything you want to do and you're not
restricted by this sort of concept of
what a vector is if you want to deal
with especially on the SPU where you can
you can freely deal with them as
integers or floats or whatever
seamlessly without cost there's there's
plenty that you can do with a
floating-point number
if you treat it as an integer and when
you win on either altivec or the SPU
where you can do that without cost
there's a huge advantage to just doing
it straight well I'm saying ready to
assembly but if you have to use the
intrinsics but certainly don't write it
back to class so memory management
static allocation is always preferred to
dynamic basically a general-purpose
dynamic memory allocation malloc free
whatever has us absolutely no place in
games we don't have a we don't have
enough unknowns for that to be valuable
we have we can group our data by
specific types we know basic ranges of
those types the vast majority of the
data is known in advance it's actually
burped on to the dips we can actually
analyze that so most of our allocations
can be calculated in advance so you load
the level and oftentimes you just load
load memory in off the disk into memory
and then fix up the pointers if you for
things that change during the runtime
just simple hierarchical allocators
block allocators where you have fixed
sizes is the easiest and best way is
always the easiest and best way to go
these are known types known
the key to that is to organize your data
so that it is actually that's actually a
workable solution so you don't have
these sort of classes or structures that
are dynamically sized that you group
them in terms of things that are similar
physics data here and and AI data is
separately here in a separate array and
that way those sort of chunks of data
are similarly sizing weed block
allocated without any fragmentation
issues at all so eventually you'll
probably you'll probably want to design
an allocator the things to consider are
the page sizes that's critically
important you want to work in within a
page as much as you possibly can so you
want to group things not necessarily the
same things but the things that will be
read together are written together
within the same page so you want to have
an a concept of the actual page up
through the system the most common thing
that probably the most common mistake I
see in a block allocator so somebody
says everybody knows what I mean by
block allocator
yeah okay so the most common mistake I
see people make is that they do least
recently used they just grabbed the most
released recently used block and use
that when somebody requests that's
actually pretty much the worst thing you
can possibly do because that's the
absolute most likely thing to be cold
it's the most likely thing to be out of
cache both out of l1 and l2 just first
the easiest thing you can do to change
it is just use most recently used just
go up the other way I mean there are
much more common much more complicated
systems you can use but just that one
small change where you're much more
likely to get warm data is going to give
you a big boost and again like I said
use hierarchies of allocations instead
of tabbing of these sort of static block
allocations instead of trying to have
one general-purpose super mega allocator
that does everything and again if it's
well planned fragmentation is not an
issue it's impossible cache line oh and
probably another important concept to
keep in mind as you're writing an
alligator is the transfer block size of
the SPU
if you have a 16 K block and the system
is aware of 16 K blocks then you can you
there are plenty of cases where you
don't have to keep track of in the
system the size of things is just how
many blocks do you have how many SPU
blocks do you have or what percentage of
SP blocks you have and that will help
you can sort of compress down your your
memory requirements when you're
referring to two blocks of memory and
streams of memory yeah you also write
overlay managers for code well I mean
just data you just load it in for games
right so like are you I know I've use
overlay manager as a part of the SDK
right well well they um overlay support
right
that's not something move it every year
and in general I mean I guess that's
probably so an interesting question of
how tall ground up what's that I'll call
your development roundup you don't yeah
yeah for the most part there are for us
that's definitely true there are there
are studios that especially
cross-platform studios that will take
middleware development and just sort of
use it at all high level but especially
when you're starting a first generation
platform game there's virtually nothing
there to use because the hardware isn't
been around long enough for anybody else
to write anything either so you if you
need it you write it yourself plus
that's just sort of the the general
theme of game development it's custom to
your situation to your data and anything
that's general-purpose enough to sell as
middleware is probably not going to be
fast enough
to run a triple-a title not always true
but as a general rule it's it's pretty
bad
okay so close how did I get here
all right yes it's nice
so coach here's another example of how
the SPU might are that the cell might
affect design so you're writing a
closing detection system the it's a it's
obvious that you cannot or should not
expect immediate results from a
collision detection system otherwise
you're gonna be sitting in sinking all
the time
for one result and performance just goes
out the window you may as well just have
a serial program so you want to group
results you want to group queries and
you want but potentially for those for
those queries to be deferred so that you
can store them you can just do them DMA
them out and then whatever process
needed them we'll come back and grab
them later so conceptually that's the
design you want to build into a closing
detection system which then in turn
affects the high-level design so AI
scripts any game code that might have
previously depended on a result being
immediately available I said they they
have characters that shoot rays around
the room to see to decide what they're
going to do next or bullets that are
flying through the air or whatever can
no longer make that assumption so they
have to be able to group up their
queries and look them up later and have
other work to do in the meantime so this
is a perfect example of how you cannot
take old code and move it to the ps3
because old code serial code would have
definitely assumed that the results were
immediately available because honestly
that was the fastest way to do it
and okay so so on a separate issue we
have SP decomposition for for the
geometry lookup so from a high level you
have your entire scene in the level or
the world or what
and you have this set of queries of how
in the case of static did I collide with
anything in the world or you ever raged
and where does this afraid collide with
something in the world and so you have
this problem if you have this large sort
of memory database in main Ram and you
have the smallest view which obviously
cannot read in the whole database
analyze it and spit out the result it
has to go back and forth to two main Ram
in order to bill its result so the
question is how do you decompose the
memory in the first place to make that
at least somewhat reasonably efficient
the first sort of instinct I think based
on history is a sort of the traditional
scene graph structures like BSP tree or
och tree or something like that and most
and particularly on the SPU because of
TLB misses that becomes really expensive
really quickly when you're basically
hitting random memory on every single
node on the tree so what you want to do
is you want to make that hierarchy as
flat as you possibly can if those if the
leaves have to be bigger that's fine it
is it turns out it's much much cheaper
to stream in a bigger group of as much
data as you can fit into the SPU and run
through it and make your decision and
spit it back out than it is to traverse
the hierarchy so you basically the depth
of your hierarchy in your in your scene
in your scene database is completely
determined by how much data you can fit
into the SPU by the maximum size of an
eighth note and the ret and the the rest
of the DEP is only there because you
don't have any other choice you know
basically the same thing goes with with
dynamic geometry as you have geometry
moving around in the scene characters
moving around the scene they basically
need to update themselves into into
their own database into their own leaves
and they'll do this in groups and then
when you query you're basically wanted
to query as many of those as possible as
you can possibly fit in at once so you
could have a sort of a broad face
collision
first where you have all of the groups
of characters that are potentially
maximum in this leaf so a bounding box
or whatever so even though there's you
could in theory in principle narrow that
down even more the cost for that the
cost for the potential memory miss for
that is so high that you just want to do
a linear search through as many as you
possibly can on an SP you does that make
sense
procedural graphics so although we have
a GPU on on the PlayStation 3 it does
turn out that the SPU is a lot better at
doing a lot of things so things like
basically where you rent where you
create geometry for the for the RSX to
rent to add to render so particle system
dynamic particle systems especially
weather systems have to interact with
the world in some way which would be
much more expensive on the GPU sort of a
dynamic systems like cloth fonts is
actually really interesting because
typically you'll just see bitmap fonts
and which because they're just textures
but if you have a very complex user
interface that just the size of the
bitmap becomes extremely extreme and if
you compress them they look terrible
especially fonts fonts need to look
perfect so if you do do procedural fonts
for example to type fonts the cost of
rendering a font actually gets
significant and in this case the SPU is
actually a great use for rendering a
procedural font rendering textures do
the same basically the same cases font
procedural textures like if you're doing
noise based clouds or something like
that and parametric geometry took NURBS
or subdivision surfaces or something
like that is a perfect case for the SPU
was there question
geometry database okay first thing seen
graphs are worthless okay
well that's a question it totally
depends I mean in general through a game
or through at least a particular area of
a game right the SPU setup is stable so
if we decide you're going to have this
SPU dedicated to physics for example
right it's very likely that that SPU is
stable and it's going to be dedicated
for physics at least for some period of
time through the level or through the
zone or whatever it is sometimes a
certain target right so there are there
are going to be elements of that where
it's where it's sort of a well balanced
problem where there's basically no way
you're gonna get waste it's always gonna
be full it's always gonna be busy
collision detection and physics are the
two things that can that you'll never
have enough cpu to do you can always use
work more CPU and basically the rest ya
can be dynamically scheduled and the
question of how to schedule it is
actually an interesting problem I it's
my opinion that the sort of looking for
the universal scheduler that solves all
problems and magically makes everything
work is a total loss cause you have more
than enough data to work with in in your
game to decide how to schedule your
SPU's basically manually and it's just
not that complicated we have six SPU's
how to schedule success views is just
not that complicated the problem you
could write it down on a piece of paper
okay so scene graphs are almost almost
always universally a complete waste of
time they store way too much data for no
apparent reason
store your databases independently based
on what you're actually doing with them
optimize your data separately because
you're accessing it separately the only
thing that should be linking your sort
of domain objects is a key that says all
right well exists in this database and
the state of base and this database but
to have this sort of giant structure
that keeps all the data for each element
in the scene is about the poorest
performing you can imagine for both
cache and TLB and SPU because you can't
fit any individual node in the SPU so I
think it covered that
oh so geometry interesting examples what
you want to do is if you have like you
have the table of queries that you have
bunch of people over the course of a
frame say I want to know if I collided
with something and then if you make
basically make a presort pass on that
and basically spatially sort these guys
together and so let's say you have
however many you can fit in the SPU lets
you have four four of these queries
together although they might be a little
further apart then you would hope you
could say basically you could basically
create a bounding box do a single query
on the database that's the sum of all of
them and then like as I said now you
have a linear list that you can just
stream through for all of them so even
though it's doing more work for any
individual one the overhead is reduced
so significantly that the end result is
that it's significantly faster and
that's awesome what I mean by multiple
simultaneous lookups basically you want
to group queries together but make sure
that there's some advantage to that by
spatially pre-sorting them there is an
advantage to that because it's more
likely that that they'll have
overlapping queries so game logic stuff
that would that the cell would affect in
game logic state machines
our good example if you defer your logic
lines and defer your results SPS are
amazingly perfect for defining state
machines
if you expect your logic lines to be
immediately available across the entire
system SPU is absolutely horrid so if
you basically write buffers into your
state machines or your logic machines
then each SPU can be cranking on
multiple state machine that wants where
all the input and all the output lines
are assumed to be deferred and it's just
an extremely straightforward process
scripting so scripting things like I
don't know Lewis script or C script or
something like that thank you I mean
obviously the first thing to look at it
this size of the interpreter will it fit
into an SPU to begin with another option
to consider is can it be can it be
converted into a few code either offline
or dynamically because you'll find that
most off-the-shelf scripting languages
are scalar sequential scripting
languages so all of the P code within
this within the script within the
scripting language itself basically
defines scalar access so not only are
you switching on every byte or every two
bytes or whatever so it's sort of poorly
performing code from an SPU point of
view but it's also poorly performing
code from a memory point of view so I
guess the question is whether or not you
can optimize the script itself didn't
turn it into SPU code that you can then
dynamically load or come up with a new
script that's just much more friendly
for for the SPU's another option if you
have to if you have to use a single sort
of scalar scripting language like Lua or
C script or whatever if you can run
multiple streams simultaneously so that
while you're doing these sort of
individual offline memory lookups and
reads and writes to main memory that you
can have that once the one blocks you
can start moving on another one as long
as there's no
dependencies between these two scripts
you should be able to stream them both
simultaneously motion control is
actually turns out to be a critical
problem in games in general that's often
overlooked its who controls the motion
in a game is it the is it the AI so is
it the the the controller in the case of
the player right I say push forward so
the guy moves forward is that really
what controls it or is it the physics so
the all of the AI does to say I want to
move forward tells the physic system I
want to move forward the physics tries
to follow it or is the animation you
have the animators actually put
translation in the animation so is that
translation the thing that's actually
driving the motion and everything else
is trying to follow it turns out to be a
surprisingly difficult problem to solve
in every studio ends up with their own
with their own solution I forget what
point I was making on name what how the
cell affected that decision but right
well I think I think the point probably
that I was trying to make is that
because you want everything to be
deferred anyway that then the order
there does become a clearer sort of
winner in that order
where you you want the can you want the
immediate feedback from the controls the
control leads the way you have the
physics which didn't follows perhaps
even a frame behind that to say how that
that new position is impacted by the
physical reality of the world and then
potentially a frame behind that or half
a frame behind that you have the
animation system which in that case
would just be basically a visual
representation of what's going on rather
than leading anything it's basically an
icon for what's happening and the
physics and the and the so when you when
you the limitations of your system are
that it has to be deferred and that has
to be done in groups basically some of
these sort of really difficult decisions
have only one or two obvious answers
all right well I wanted to dig into
animation a little bit so does anybody
have any questions on anything you know
sort of the high level stuff does this
need break-in to break the desire for
the higher level programmers to abstract
what's going on well if we get again
listen we get gameplay programmer right
fresh out of school it's time school C++
in school taught to decompose the world
into the sort of domain classes and that
they all communicate through each other
maybe through messaging all right well
the first thing we tell them is that all
that is complete crap none of that will
actually work in practice
so in some sense yes there is a sort of
tendency for them to want this interface
this sort of clean abstraction but
abstraction doesn't have any value
doesn't make the game faster cheaper
programmers and they have different
priorities but I have different
experiences so yeah in that way there is
a division so this two content animation
a little bit so let's just start with
let's start with trying trying to build
a simple animation system and see what
problems come creep up as we're trying
to implement on the cell right so tip in
the simplest case we have a set of
animation channels defined for a
character which is made up of joints
right we're just talking about sort of a
simple hierarchical transformation here
and some of those channels are related
so in the case of like rotation plus
translation plus scale equals a any
individual joint so the first thing
typically that will that you'll have to
answer is whether or not you want to do
Euler a quaternion rotation now the the
first a tendency I guess especially for
new programmers is to go with quaternion
they're taught that gimbal lock is a
sort of insurmountable problem that only
quaternions solve and that's just simply
not true
I mean gimbal lock is completely
manageable in practice what we need to
trying to rotate on three axes and two
axes rotate 90 degrees apart and the
third axis can't be resolved or 180
degrees apart and so you can't resolve
one of the axes right yeah it's where
you can't resolve one it's impossible to
resolve one of the axes and that's this
that's a nature of Euler sort of
rotation and so but sort of a quaternion
rotation composedly solves that that
mathematical problem it's all it's
always resolvable and it's not it's not
very messy at all I mean from a from a
sort of C++ programmers perspective it
looks clean the math is clean everything
is clean about it unfortunately it
doesn't compress for
well at all were were if you use oiler
rotation which basically just means the
the individual rotation for every axis
so X rotation Y rotation Z rotation
right that's much much more compressible
because each one of those axes can be
individually compressed it's very
unlikely that you're always rotating in
all three axes all the time especially
in a human character it's much more
likely that only one axis is rotating on
any one given time and so that makes it
oh.just without any change without any
additional compression it tends to make
it about a third of the size we're
talking so would you have the frame of
animation which is all these animation
channels right and then over time you
have these sort of different frames of
animation right if he store for every
joint for every rotation that would join
you store quaternion over over time it's
hard to compress across time because
you're basically essentially rotating
all three axes all the time well with
yeah alright and the question so let's
say of course the next step is how do we
store the actual rotation itself do we
store it in float double 1/2 precision
fixed point position the probably the
natural tendency at this point would be
to store it in a floating-point number
but if you look at the actual range of
rotation which is extremely limited on a
character on any particular joint there
are very few joints that would even
rotate 180 degrees so a floating point
is is overkill by a large margin on
rotation for the for the range for the
precision however it's fairly good
especially between very small rotations
over a long period of time so probably a
more balanced approach would be to go
with a 16-bit floating-point format a
half format where you keep most of the
precision but you reduce the range
significantly
there's also a potential for going with
an 8-bit floating-point format depending
on the kind of animation that you're
doing and I probably have this on
another slide but it really depends on
how close the how compressible a a joint
in it depends on how close to the root
it is the further away from the root the
less it matters so the joint at your
fingertip you can compress a whole lot
more because it doesn't matter as much
because it's not going to affect
anything else where a joint at the
actual root and the smallest change in
motion will affect the entire system and
animation and will make it virtually
impossible for you to line up animations
with each other so that particular joint
needs to be nearly perfect and how do
you store rotations you store them in
degrees radians or normalized
I have seen people store them in degrees
I don't understand why you would ever do
that it's just adding math to the
problem radians is perfectly fine if
you're using off-the-shelf off-the-shelf
trigonometric functions 10 sine whatever
but typically if you're gonna optimize
those functions yourself anyway it's
going to be much more effective to go
with the normalized rotation of value B
so basically between 0 & 1 & makes it
makes it a lot easier to do to do tricks
based on the circle basically you can
just take the fractional value and just
deal with that so normalized rotation is
generally the width the way to go and I
normalized in 1/2 precision is probably
the even bet for for how you would store
so looking at how what we need to fit
into an SPU if we're gonna be running
for an animation yeah
what's the key driver magazine yes you
has very little space yeah well okay
there's there's two factors really and
on see right so starting with the SP you
that you have to be able to to go work
through this data on the SPO but but but
you also have the DMA transfer itself
the SP you can actually calculate really
really fast right and that's the whole
point so if you can transfer it less
data burn through it a little bit to
expand it it's actually a huge win and
on top of that we have a big big game
and only 256 Meg's right and the amount
of geometry that people require from
from current generation gaming
our next generation game is has scaled
up way more than the amount of memory
we've been given so we've only been
given hmm eight times as much memory as
we had the previous generation the
people expect significantly more than
eight times as much geometry on the
screen and where do we store that we
have the blu-ray right but we can't be
streaming everything off the disk all
the time
which is to another point you have you
know you have 40 gigs of data on your
disk but only 200 6 Meg's around right
so there's this sort of series of you
know of compression and decompression to
keep everything in basically think of
RAM as thank you your l3 cache right so
we've looked at what we want to store on
the next few basically the goal of this
is we want to get an entire animation
for a particular skeleton on an SVU so
that we can transform the skeleton and
output the resulting joint data so let's
look at how big that would have to be so
first we start with the basic 9 channels
per joint that's not assuming in in a
game you'd probably have additional
channels like footstep channels and
sound channels and other sort of
animation channels to help actually
a game but in this case we just want to
animate the character so we have
rotation times three translation times
three and and scale times three so the
first thing to drop to and this will
cover this will reduce your data by 70%
is all the uniform channels so any data
that doesn't actually change across the
entire length of the animation
it may not be zero but it could be just
one thing one value that doesn't change
across the length of the animation so
you pull the uniform channels out and
most things that's going to be scale for
example most joints don't scale although
occasionally they do and translation in
a human our joints don't translate
however in real and in a when you
actually animate a character in order to
get particular effects in order to make
it look more human you do you end up
needing to translate joints so we can
reduce so but in order to do that we
need to build a a map basically a table
of these uniform channels so now we know
this table of uniform channels has to be
stored in the SPU along with down the
remaining actual animation data of
course multiplied by by the number of of
joints so now we have what is
essentially raw animation data so for
the sake of argument let's say this the
animation data is has been has been
baked out by Maya or whatever at 30
frames a second we've pulled off the
uniform data so now we have for the
joints that do move we have these curves
over time over the entire length of the
animation the problem is if that
animation is ten seconds long it's now
way too big to fit in the SPU by a large
margin so how do we sort of compress it
down so that it actually will fit again
just first of all just the easiest thing
to do to start with is just do simple
curve fitting to get rid of the things
that don't need to be there that you can
easily calculate out and again the
closer you are to the route the title
that fit needs to be conversely the
further away you are from the route you
can loosen up the restrictions a little
bit and have a little bit
to fit on the curve and compress a
little bit more so if you if you do need
curve fitting with the simple spline
basically the the one of the you have
you have to store your time values in
the places that were calculated part of
the problem is now you have sort of
these individual scalars with time can
be randomly spread throughout the entire
animation so any point where there's
basically a knot in the curve there's a
there's a time value and all none of
these knots are going to line up with
each other in any of these animation
channels so in principle if you wanted
to code this you would have to basically
say what is time right now and loop
through each of these scalar values find
out where time is calculate the position
on the curve and then spit out the
result and so one you still have to have
the the unlimited length of data and to
you're looping through scalar values on
the SPU which is really actually
horrible
so we want to find a way to solve that
problem probably the most trivial
solution is do spline segments you lose
some compressibility but it solves the
problem basically you split up the
spline into at least a sections of 16
value of 16 Knox and you just do that
just and in order to do that you just
need a table you need to add a table
that says what the range of time are in
each of those groups of 16 knots for
every channel so when you're going to
transform the animation first you load
this table in you say what's my time
right now at time T you go and say which
blocks which segments of the spine needs
to load in for each channel you load
those in so now you have basically one
section of the spline which is probably
which is too big probably for the
current T but its covers it covers what
T you're actually in so one block one
one block of spline for every single
channel so the advantage of this now
that that the spline is sort into
intersections is that rather than having
all the spline data stored sort of
linearly you can now reorder the blocks
so that that the the spline data from
different channels is actually tiled
next to each other so that when you
actually go to do a load it's much more
likely because you know you're going to
be requesting all these channels at once
and all in the same time T you can find
a more or less optimal ordering that'll
allow more of these things to be grouped
in the same cache or at least the same
the same page so in the advantage of
course again is the length of animation
makes no absolutely no difference at all
the disadvantage is it's less
compressible because you can only
basically compress this one section of
the curve but the advantage huge
advantages it solves a scalar loop
problem so now you can take four
yeah you can take four of these scalar
values all with a fixed known number of
knots in it and just loop through all of
the knots in principle you could search
through and find a minimum number of
knots to look through for each one of
the scalars but in practice it's much
faster just look through all four
simultaneously for all 16 knots and just
throw away the results that are invalid
as you're going through it that way you
can use the the SP instruction set you
can load quadword store quadwords and do
everything in a minimum single loop
which you can completely unroll well
basically the excuse are taking this
channel animation data right and baking
it out into well for the in the easiest
case baking it out into a 4 by 4 matrix
per joint insignificant but it's much
smaller
by the animation it is I mean you know
just are just outputting the joint
information independently we have the
skimming problem independently there's a
rendering problem this is just baking
animation okay I'm probably I'm just
gonna skip through this because this
could take a long time what basically
what I wanted to say here was take the
let's take the next step of that
animation let's add some dynamic support
the easiest thing to do is just to
create a second uniform data table that
you've been blend with the first one and
that one in principle is basically all
of the channels and then now a gameplay
programmer can go and individually set
any of those so they can tweak the head
or whatever and that's definitely
compressible cuz it's very unlikely
they're going to moving all the joints
at once so you just create you can
create a secondary map that says these
are the this is the number of joints
that are dynamic these are the this is
how they map to the uniform values but
then once you add any kind of dynamic
support you have now complicated the
problem significantly because now in in
reality what you need are constraints
you need to be able to have a limit to
how high the head can move because
what's gonna happen is only you could
just say the head could only move so
much if that movement is algorithmic so
let's say follow a character or whatever
it's it's going to go outside of
reasonable constraints really quickly so
it's much cleaner and simpler to support
that in in the in the on the engine size
we're basically defined constraints for
the joints and then let the the
high-level code so yeah you can have max
change over time so it only can move so
fast the max range of motion the max
acceleration is actually a really harder
problem because it implies that you need
to store the the change over time which
we're not actually
which would probably blow our memory on
the SPU so as far as impacting an
animation that would I would immediately
throw out max acceleration if an
animator were to come to me and say this
is a a feature that I wanted I would say
it's unlikely because it's unlikely we
can fit it on the SPU whereas on the PC
it might be a different story and blend
in information how you blend these
things together
well anyway let's what's that okay so
there so as far as mixing there's
there's plenty of additional problems in
mixing animation phase matching so for
example you have a run and a walk
basically all that means is if you were
going to blend from a run to a walk you
kind of want to blend in basically
essentially the same leg positions
because if you just blend from the
middle of an animation to the beginning
of the animation it's unlikely the legs
are going to match and for the
transition time you're going to see this
scissoring of the legs would you see
that in plenty of games but especially
in next generation especially as
characters get look more complicated
they are expected to act more
complicated transitions handling either
either programmatic transitions between
animations so we have an animation
that's standing in a mission that's
crouching and use sort of with
constraints move them down or
artist-driven
animated transitions and/or both
translation matching is actually an
interesting problem so you have an
animation that's running in you have an
animation that's walk in they both
translate obviously at different speeds
nonlinearly and you want to slowly run
down into a walk but you have to match
these sort of nonlinear translations as
his feet are stepping onto the ground
turns out to be a really difficult
problem to get perfectly right
especially if you have IKEA on the feet
where he's walking on the ground and may
be walking uphill or downhill and the
translation is being affected
the world and a lot of cases you'll see
people be pretty much just ignore this
problem but it is something to consider
going forward and this is something that
we would we would consider how to solve
regardless of whether or not we could
get it in as far as actually rendering
the geometry goes so you have you you
now have your certain matrices of joints
and you have a let's say you said we
want to send those to the to the GPU and
what along with the geometry to skin and
render now the question is do you single
or double buffer those joints because
right now basically the RSX community p
you could be reading these these joints
in in parallel to when you're actually
outputting them sort of the the
traditional approach so the easiest
approach is just to double up for the
joints so just output into a different
buffer than the r6 is reading from it's
one frame or half a frame behind doesn't
much matter but it also doubles now your
space of your joints one advantage that
games have is that a frame is a
well-defined element in the game so we
know and we know what needs to happen
across the course of a frame so these
characters need to be rendered this
background needs to be the collisions
back things to having physics needs to
happen here so you can within a frame
set it up so that the update from the
SPU's and the read from the from the GPU
can never overlap even without any kind
of synchronization or or lock it can be
a well-known fact that it's impossible
for these two things because there's
actually something in the middle
happening that has its own
synchronization primitive and so there's
and that will allow you to do single
buffering of the data but it does
require more organization every way
especially if you're doing it on more
than just one case so you have all these
things that you want single buffered so
you need to organize it with and
organize them within the frame so
they're never updating and reading at
the same time
oh and I just want a Sawbuck this is the
last point I'll make optimization one of
the things that you'll hear save
optimization till the end my point here
being is if you save optimization to the
end you don't know how to do it because
you haven't actually practiced it if you
haven't practiced it you don't know what
to do so we'll take much longer
you should always be optimizing in order
to understand when it actually counts
what to do and the fact that real
optimization does impact the design all
the way up optimization of the hardware
impact smell engine design how the
engine is designed to be fast does
impact the data it impacts how gameplay
needs to needs to be written high-level
code needs to be called so if you save
optimization to last what you're doing
is completely limiting what you can
optimize and the idea that it's the root
of all evil certainly didn't come from a
game developer anyway that's it that was
a Call of Duty 3 came out on the Xbox
and on the ps3 is the is 33 and the ps3
just running on the SPU then or is it
actually no that's very likely using
this piece no no no I don't look to sort
code but I suspect that she's an SP is
how efficiently it's using them is an
entirely different question but it's
easy to take sort of the most trivial
things right the most say you just do
hotspot analysis on your your your
sequential code and say okay well I can
grab this section of thing and put it on
the SPU right and just the heaviest
hitters if at the moment ask for you
that's pretty easy to do just take it up
to the next level though and to really
have
that sort of the next-gen of game you've
now there's nowhere to go from there one
there's nowhere to go from that analysis
you've already sort of hit the limit of
what you can do with that it has to be
redesigned so I don't know what they're
doing honestly but and certainly I'm
being recorded so yeah yeah I'm song man
Seuk resistance okay so that was more
like all these things you had to read it
hmm what else is there you know games
look better is like consoles website
goes on what else is there that you guys
plan changing as far as working with the
processor there's plenty more to be
optimized it's it's down the cost and
scheduling those things I mean we have a
team of people who now really understand
the platform and whereas a lot of what I
went into previous tiles was mixed with
learning curve right so there's there
there is definitely potential for going
back and improving things to make it
look better and that's what game do
that's what a cycle of game development
is all about I mean games at the end of
the lifetime of PlayStation 3 will look
significantly better than released
titles its way it always is the head of
Sony Computer Entertainment said that
ps3 pretty soon will be customizable it
would be able to be different types of
amounts of RAM and whatnot well I leave
any in that case I was talking
specifically about a like a ps3 based
like TiVo kind of weird media thing
which has nothing to do with us we're
not stuck that's what we have I mean I
don't see it as stuck I would much
rather have the mission I mean that's
what console development is about really
we have a machine we understand the
limitations of it and we can push that
machine over the lifetime of the
platform if it changes out from under us
it becomes PC development are you
allowed to
the 7s fuse or you just don't know how
much I can answer this just from NDA
point of you but let's say
hypothetically they're magically became
more right
probably nothing would happen the game
has to be optimized for the minimum case
so nothing would change nothing else
yeah lifecycle like for the engine of
the game don't assume I don't assume you
start by prototyping in a higher-level
language then completing this to the
design for performance aspects like how
do you how do you build up I even build
up from empty no you don't start with
empty that's a that's the perspective
difference you don't start with code
codes not important start with the data
you sit down with an artist and say what
do you want to do and then you look at
the data what does the data look like
what Co is this animation database but
it all starts with the data it all
starts with sort of that concept of what
do we want to see on the screen what do
we don't want to hear the speakers what
kind of effects we want and actually
look at that from the perspective of
whoever the content creator and welcome
what they're generating and what we can
do with that data
because game development is this black
box between the artists and the screen
we're providing a transformation engine
you know that takes the vision of the
designers and the artist and just
transforming it and spinning it onto the
screen so we where you really need to
start is with their sources of data
you've been doing game developer 11
years
have you had a favorite platform and a
name your platform is there I've been
pretty much with the PlayStation
platform since there was a PlayStation
platform and I don't know it's hard to
get perspective because you get in it
and you were always really loved the
platform you're working on so it's hard
I mean it's hard to get perspective I
can't today's ten years ago right so
well like okay with the piste I think
some of the things that I like about
history which is sort of different
question are the the fact that the cell
is much more public than any other
platform has ever been with IBM's
documentation with the Shiva support and
Sony support we've never had I've never
had a platform where I could you know
get up on a website and actually talk
about it outside of NDA and that for me
is an amazing change where I can go and
talk to other people exactly like this
group here that have used the same exact
platform I abused
that's never been able to happen before
so even on ps2 for quite a long part of
the lifespan even though there was a
Linux eventually on the ps2 virtually
everything was covered by NDA because
there was no independent release of
information so that's one of the great
things about the ps3 for me public